you've uh spoke to me
a little bit of russian where does that
come from so your
your appreciation of tolstoy but also
your ability to speak a bit of russian
where's that
where is that from so uh i speak in
addition to english i speak
reasonably well depending on how much
vodka i've had
russian french and german um i learned
those
uh for uh research purposes i learned
french actually when i was in high
school
russian when i was in college german
when i was in graduate school
now i do have family on my mother's side
that's a russian jewish extraction
um but they were yiddish speakers by the
time you know i met them by the time
they had gone through germany and come
to the united states or really gone
through poland and come the united
states they were yiddish speakers so
there's no one really in my family who
speaks russian
but i do feel a connection there at
least a long range
personal connection is there something
to be said about the language
and your ability to imagine history
sort of when you study these different
countries
your ability to imagine what it was like
to be
um a part of that culture part of that
time
yes language is crucial to understanding
a culture and
even if you learn the language as i have
you learning russian and german and
french
it's still not the same as also being a
native speaker either as you know um
but i think language tells you a lot
about mannerism
about assumptions uh the very fact that
english doesn't
have a formal you but russian has a
formally right
versus right german has a formal you z
versus d right so the fact that english
doesn't have a formal u
tells you something uh about americans
right that's just one example
uh the fact that um you know that
germans have such a wider vocabulary
for certain scientific concepts than we
have in english tells you something
about the culture right language
is an artifact of the culture the
culture makes the language
it's fascinating to explore i mean even
just exactly what you just said
which is there's a fascinating
transition
so i guess in english we just have you
yeah
there's a there's a fascinating
transition that persists to this day
is is of formalism and politeness
where it's an initial kind of dance of
interaction that's
uh different methods
of signaling respect i guess we don't
then language provides that in the
united in the english language
there's fewer tools to show that kind of
respect which has
potentially positive or negative effects
on it flattens the society where like a
teenager could talk to an older person
and show like uh like a difference
i mean but at the same time i mean it
creates a certain kind of dynamic a
certain kind of society
and it's funny to think of just like
those few words can have any like a
ripple effect
through the whole culture and we don't
have a history in the united states of
of aristocracy
yeah the these uh elements of language
reflect aristocracy the the the serf
would never refer to the master even if
the master is younger
it's always void right of it's always
right i mean and so
it's um yeah so it tells you something
about the history that's why to your
question which was a great question it's
so crucial
to try to penetrate the language i'll
also say something else
and this is a problem for many americans
who haven't learned a foreign language
we're very bad at teaching foreign
languages
if you've never taught yourself a
foreign language
you have closed yourself off to certain
kinds of empathy
because you have basically trained your
brain to only look at the world one way
the very act of learning another
language i think tells your brain
that words and concepts don't translate
one-to-one
this is the first thing you realize
right we can say you know these two
words mean the same thing from two
languages they never mean exactly
yeah it's the same thing right dos
vidonia is really not goodbye
yes right and there's something you know
right now there's people talking about
idea of lived experience
one of the ways to force yourself into
this idea
of liv's experiences by learning another
language is to understand that
you can perceive the world in a totally
different way even even though you're
perceiving the same thing
and of course the way to first learn
russian for those
looking for tutorial lessons for me is
just like as you said
you start by drinking lots of vodka yes
of course it's very difficult
to do otherwise
you